but please you need some info on the
food to Lanka Soros the Barrow searches
and the die sign are done where do you
go Wikipedia thanks Noble Michi oh no
problem
how do we know what these prehistoric
creatures look like lots of careful
research and attention to details we had
a unit hi Jordan we really offer well a
lot on them
this is no Momiji Tamura
hello and he's got a pretty cool teacher
I'm working at the advanced light source
Lawrence Berkeley National Laboratory
and my job here is to take care of this
machine it's like a depression in
station the micros different would my
could be fashion and station but it's at
night in on weekends that Nobu channels
the scientific know-how into his
dinosaur drawings it's called pani lot
my bad
paleo art is an original artistic
creation that depicts prehistoric life
according to the latest research right
now boo exactly it's a combination of
science and creativity so I basically
read the latest discovery on my stomach
animals based on that I turn up this is
what I've been doing for the last eight
years and never got a lot to show for it
by his estimate he's published over 1500
drawings including seven this book that
he co-authored but it wasn't always
smooth sailing the first drawing that
was one of a dinosaur called cosmos
always but it was taken out by the
editors because it wasn't accurate
enough that's okay Nobu can't bat a
thousand it's not the Baseball Reference
I'm French I got it not every baguette
can be perfect well I don't here wait
wait wait come back come back come back
you